buonasera finché valenza pensare con le
mani quindi assolutamente ben poca
analogia a disposizione se non quella
più va assolutamente voluta che sono le
nostre mani finché by hand è un è
diventato di fatto una sorta anche di
brand viene utilizzato ad esempio
all'interno di alcune metodologie come
quella che a me capita spesso di
utilizzare che poi magari vi proveremo
per qualche minuto che prevede
l'utilizzo di materiali come i lego e
che parte dalla dalla concezione che
l'utilizzo delle mani l'abbinamento in
tempo reale di azione e pensiero
consente alle persone di rendere più
veloce più efficace più rapido il
pensiero la capacità di apprendere la
capacità di generare significati la
capacità di comunicare di rendere le
cose più chiare
consapevoli a sé e agli altri quindi
finché in vacanza qui abbiamo un
problema soprattutto se la bici dalla
vostra di vostra figlia è un grosso
problema perché ovviamente non è
semplicemente un forum è un gioco che
non si può usare e allora detto ma e
sabato non posso andare da un ciclista
ormai è sera ma io da piccolo mi
riparavo da solo le biciclette quando
erano bucate cambiavo le camere d'aria
mettevo le pezze con il mastice usavo il
catino dell'acqua per cercare la bolla
lo devo fare
lo devo fare ho rivoltato la bicicletta
ci ho messo un paio d'ore ma piano piano
le mani hanno ritrovato il sentiero
piano piano si è risvegliata quella
conoscenza che si era sedimentata nel
tempo di quando ero piccolo di quando
facevo questo questa attività da solo
insieme a mio padre
questo per dire che cosa che quando noi
costruiamo con le nostre mani facciamo
qualcosa questa conoscenza in qualche
modo si sedimenta diventa più
consapevole rimane dentro di noi in
maniera indelebile
a volte si tratta solo di andare a
risvegliare questo gigante dormiente
riportare a galla questa questa
conoscenza che abbiamo acquisito nel
fare quindi in questo senso pensare con
le
consente di migliorare la capacità di
apprendere e di sedimentare i livelli di
conoscenza di apprendimento di
consapevolezza da montessori già già lei
diceva che le mani sono l'organo
dell'intelligenza attraverso le mani
prendiamo possesso della realtà
diamo significato alle cose creiamo il
mondo che ci sta intorno
costruiamo significati einstein è famoso
per aver detto che la logica ci porta
dhabi l'immaginazione ci porta ovunque
non voglio essere presuntuoso ma penso
che sia un po incompleta questa frase è
che forse fosse e che forse fosse più
completo il punto di vista di maria
montessori che diceva se l'immaginazione
non viene messa a terra non si tramuta
in qualcosa di concreto in un'attività
in una creazione rimane qualcosa di
sospeso quasi di etereo
ecco l'immaginazione le mani aiutano a
dare un senso a dare una forma a
trasferire in qualcosa di concreto di
realizzabile di comunicabile ciò che noi
riusciamo ad immaginare ci sono anche
diversi studi che dimostrano come
appunto sia di fatto siano più le mani a
creare si è in qualche modo la nostra
conoscenza e non è tanto il cervello e
facendo che abbia che che anche il
cervello evolve crea crea nuove nuove
opportunità di conoscenza di crescita di
maturazione di sviluppo questa è una
un'immagine di come saremmo se fossimo
in proporzioni a quelle che sono le
nostre connessioni neurali avremo delle
mani grosse come orecchie di elefante
avremmo la zona delle labbra del parlato
e la zona fondamentalmente tutte le zone
dedicate ai sensi gli occhi
la parte della lingua le labbra le mani
che sarebbero estremamente grandi
sproporzionate ingombranti
invece abbiamo delle mani estremamente
proporzionate ma di una grandissima
potenzialità
io vedo quando mi capita di andare nelle
aziende nelle organizzazioni come le
persone abbiano completamente
dimenticato questo modo questo strumento
questa modalità di creare conoscenza di
entrare in contatto con la realtà di
dare forma di di apprendere di
comunicare con gli altri si diventa
molto verbosi molto verbali molto
concettuali e si dimentica quale grande
potere hanno le nostre mani nel
comunicare nel creare significati nel
rendere la comunicazione più veloce più
rapida più performante sam urp a perth
un allievo di piaget siamo sempre nel
filone dei grandi pedagogisti del
dell'inizio del secolo scorso soleva
affermare che l'apprendimento avviene in
modo migliore
quando costruisco qualcosa al di fuori
di me
e torniamo al tema della bicicletta
perché lui è lui ebbe intuizioni questa
intuizione quando come insegnante di
matematica vedeva i suoi studenti che
arrivati in aula per le sue lezioni si
accasciavano sul banco distrutte o si
addormentavano poco dopo comunque era
totalmente avulsi e disinteressati e lui
dice ma perché quando gli stessi
studenti li vedo nell'aula dove
scolpiscono con nel sapone sono così
coinvolti sono così attivi sono così
vivaci la sua intuizione è stata quella
devo trovare degli strumenti attraverso
i quali in maniera interattiva
attraverso l'operatività attraverso la
manipolazione attraverso la costruzione
io possa rendere i miei studenti tutte
le persone parte attiva del processo di
apprendimento e non parte passiva
detto questo
proviamo a farlo anche noi adesso
prenderò un po di lego debutto qui sul
tavolo vi invito a venire a prendere un
po ea provare a costruire in qualche
minuto la torre più alta che riuscite
ok siamo prego
o quelle già fatte non valgono provate a
costruire in tre minuti la torre più
alta che potete minuto e mezzo e bisogna
un po avvicinarsi intrufolarsi e questo
è 30 secondi ok ok va bene dekstop
allora che cosa potete notare perché poi
non tutti si sono alzati l'aula non è
ideale ci volevano dei bei tavoli da
picnic così poi concludevamo cosa si può
notare non c'è una torre uguale
all'altra non c'è una torre uguale
all'altra quando le persone si esprimono
mettono in campo hanno la possibilità di
esprimere se stesse emerge tutto questo
grande valore della diversità che non è
un problema anzi è una grande
opportunità non c'è un attore uguale
all'altra ma sono tutte quante torri
sono tutte quante torri allora questo
che cosa voglio dire che quando noi
diamo spazio non solo alla nostra testa
ma coinvolgiamo anche la nostra le
nostre mani la nostra pancia emerge una
rotondità di noi stessi che non ha
paragoni
quando mi capita di chiedere nelle
aziende ma descrive ti descrivi la tua
identità costruendo una metafora di ciò
che sei e poi confrontano col tuo
curriculum o comunque con quello che tu
scrivi se dovessi scrivere chi sei
da una parte abbiamo il gelo
dall'altra parte abbiamo l'umanità
perché emergono tutte tutte quelle che
sono le caratteristiche anche emotive
emozionali delle persone quindi quello
che voglio dire che la corsa usare le
mani
non è soltanto uno strumento di
apprendimento lo è
e anche un modo con cui noi riusciamo ad
esprimere ad esplorare a portare a galla
portare fuori ciò che siamo e questa è
una ricchezza perché la diversità è
sempre una ricchezza
adesso perso provate a notare questa
immagine se guardate le frecce le
persone stanno osservando i modelli
costruiti dagli altri non si stanno
guardando
ma non perché non ci siamo rispetto un
riconoscimento dell'altro ma perché
quando si utilizzano delle tecniche di
facilitazione come la costruzione come
materiali leggo altro le persone sono
portate a concentrarsi sul significato
delle cose si bypassa tutto quello che
il tutto quel livello che a volte a un
livello di complessità che frena
rallenta i lavori che riguarda le
caratteristiche delle persone
le persone discutono di ciò che gli
altri hanno hanno da dire dei modelli
che hanno costruito dentro i quali c'è
un significato non stanno parlando delle
caratteristiche dell'uno o dell'altra
che sono poi spesso quegli elementi che
rendono difficile la collaborazione tra
le persone perché si perde di vista il
contenuto il problema e ci si sposta su
un piano diverso
e tutto questo rallenta rallenta
rallenta riduce la capacità di un team
di essere performante per una start up
per chi vuole innovare è molto
importante invece riuscire a creare le
condizioni perché effettivamente ci si
possa confrontare su quelle che sono le
soluzioni su quelle che sono le proposte
su quelle che sono i contenuti su quelle
che sono le opportunità non sulle
dinamiche personali interpersonali che
ci sono tra le persone che poi sono
importanti ma che a volte spesso non
permettono di poter procedere celermente
verso l'identificazione di soluzioni
oddio hop o di assunzione di decisioni
io qui mi fermo
voglio dire semplicemente questa cosa
per concludere che utilizzare la
tridimensionalità significa operare ad
un livello che è molto più vicino al
modo con cui noi naturalmente viviamo
nel mondo
noi pensiamo vediamo ci muoviamo in una
dimensione che è tridimensionale non è
bidimensionale spesso le persone quando
ad esempio si chiede in un contesto
anche di sviluppo di idee di
brainstorming di lavoro di creazione di
significati per per per far lavorare il
team insieme vedo come le persone quando
devono lavorare scrivendo usando dei
post it e usando dei fogli vanno molto
più lente ma soprattutto in molti casi
sono in difficoltà perché ritengono che
disegnare e scrivere sia un'abilità che
io e gli altri non hanno invece
l'utilizzo delle narrazioni delle
metafore delle costruzioni rende la
possibilità di un confronto molto più
democratico molto più facile pone tutti
sullo stesso piano il contesto del play
è un contesto che in qualche modo rende
anche il clima di lavoro più sereno più
democratico e con maggiori opportunità
di confronto rispetto a quello che
possono essere i temi in discussione
tutto questo secondo io l'ho visto
rispetto a diverse aziende che ho anche
start up che ho avuto modo di seguire ho
visto che tutto questo aiuta aiuta a
rendere più efficace con questo io
concludo semplicemente ricordando ancora
finché invarianza fidatevi delle vostre
mani fidatevi delle vostre mani perché
sono un organo dell'intelligenza grazie
e buona sera
[Applauso]